if we have some mass m
and it is moving with some velocity
let's say the magnitude of that velocity
we say is v
we know that this object right over here
has momentum translational momentum and
that momentum and we use the greek
letter rho to represent momentum
translational momentum is defined as
being equal
to
the mass
times
the mass times the velocity this is all
review we have other videos where we
talk about translational momentum
and one way to think about it is well
how hard is it to to to stop this thing
i mean you literally in in everyday
language you think how much momentum
does something have you know the more
momentum it has the harder it's going to
the harder it is to to stop it in some
way
and so
we know if we want to get a little bit
more mathematical
that
if we want to change momentum we have to
apply force for some amount of time
and so the magnitude of our force
the magnitude of our force times the
duration of the time that we apply it
for
force times time and this is
called impulse and this is once again
all review
this is equal to change in momentum
so this is equal to change we do this in
that yellow color
that is equal to change
in momentum so if you don't have any
impulse especially if you don't have any
net force acting on an object its
momentum is going to be constant you
have a conservation of momentum and we
use that idea in all sorts of
interesting physics
applications in the world and especially
a lot of cases using billiard balls and
whatever else
so now let's try to take a similar idea
but go into the rotational world so
let's imagine you have a mass and for
the sake of this we're going to assume
it's a point mass
so
you have a mass there and let's just say
it's attached by essentially a massless
wire
a massless wire to
to you know it's just nailed down right
over here and so this right over here
would be its center of rotation and so
you could imagine if someone applied a
torque to this mass this mass could
start rotating in a circle and you could
just assume that it's maybe it's sitting
on a you know the screen this this is a
kind of a frictionless surface there's
no air resistance and so then it will if
you apply a torque here it will start
rotating and so you could think about
well there might be an idea just as
momentum is this idea of well how hard
is it to to stop something
you might say well how and this is stop
translating something something from
moving you might think well maybe
there's a similar idea of how hard is it
for something to or how hard is it to to
stop rotating something and you could
imagine that that idea has been defined
and it has been defined as angular
momentum so let me make this clear this
right over here
is momentum
momentum
and over here we'll talk about angular
angular
momentum
angular momentum and actually both
momentum and angular momentum are vector
quantities so here i just wrote the kind
of the magnitudes of velocity and
momentum but momentum is a vector and it
could be defined the momentum vector
could be defined as equal to the mass
which is a scalar quantity times the
velocity
times the velocity vector now the same
thing is true for angular momentum but
i'm going to stay focused on the the the
magnitude of angular momentum angular
momentum can have direction as you can
imagine you could rotate in two
different ways but that gets a little
bit more complicated when you start
thinking about taking the products of
vectors because as as you may already
know or you may see in the future
there's different ways of taking
products of vectors but just to get the
intuition of angular momentum i'll focus
on the magnitudes
so angular momentum is defined and the
letter used is l i did a lot of research
to try to figure out why it is called l
and i could not find a good reason so in
the in the message board below if anyone
has a good reason i i i i i would like
to know why it's why angular why angular
momentum is called l a lot of the best
arguments i saw is that almost
everything else was all the other
letters were used up for other ideas and
in physics but anyway angular momentum
is defined and it's defined very
similarly just as a kind of torque is a
thing that can change how something
rotates and force is the way that
something changes how something
translates it and torque is force times
distance from the center of rotation
angular everything in kind of the
rotational world is is is defined in a
similar way you kind of take the analog
in the translational world and you
multiply it times the distance from your
center of rotation so angular momentum
is defined as angular momentum is
defined as
mass
times velocity
times distance to from the center of
rotation so let's call this distance
right over here r
r for radius because you can imagine if
this is traveling in a circle that would
be the radius of the circle m v r
actually let me be a little bit more
careful here it's the magnitude of the
velocity that is perpendicular to the
radius sometimes it might be called the
tangential velocity so this symbol right
over here this is the magnitude of the
velocity that is perpendicular to the
radius so it would be this
it would be that
magnitude right over here this is what
we define as angular
as angular momentum
and what i will tell you here is just as
in the absence of a net force momentum
is constant
we know and i haven't shown it to you i
haven't proven it to you yet
mathematically but in the absence of
torque so if torque is equal to zero
we do torque in pink if torque
is equal to zero if there's no net
torque going on here if the magnitude of
torque is equal to zero
then
then we will have
then we will have no change
no
no change
in angular momentum and we will look at
that mathematically in a few seconds but
just from this there's a very
interesting thing that arises and
something that you might have observed
at even the olympics or in other things
and this is the idea that you can by
changing your radius you could actually
change your tangential velocity and as
we've seen in previous videos tangential
velocity is closely related to angular
to angular velocity so let's explore
that a little bit
so when we write it
in the world where well actually you see
it straight out of this if l is constant
if r went down so let me write this down
so
let me rewrite it over here so l
whoops
so let me write it
l
is equal to
mass
times tangential velocity or actually
well tangential velocity or the velocity
is perpendicular to the radius
times the radius
now what happens if we assume that this
is constant if we assume that this is
let me write this down if we assume that
there's no torque so we're in this world
so this over here is going to be
constant
this is going to be constant
so what happens if we were to reduce r
somehow you know this this wire started
to reel in a little bit or started to
wrap around here and actually that's
actually a reasonable thing you can
imagine as it rotates it starts to wrap
around this thing so the wire gets
shorter
so if r goes down
if r goes down and this is constant the
mass isn't going to change well if l is
constant mass isn't changing r is going
down tangential velocity or the velocity
that's perpendicular to the radius is
going to go up
velocity that is perpendicular to the
radius is going to go up
and if we want to think about it and we
can think about it in terms of angular
velocity we know
we know that angular velocity which you
would measure in radians per second we'd
use the symbol omega
omega is defined and we go into much
more depth in this in other videos as
tangential velocity
tangential velocity the velocity the the
magnitude of the velocity that is
perpendicular to the radius divided by
the radius
divided by the radius
or if you solve before tangential
velocity
you get
v is equal to
is equal to omega r
is equal to omega
omega
omega r and so if you substitute back
into this it's really this definition
for
angular momentum you get
you get angular momentum
is equal to
mass
times this times r
so mass times i'm just substituting for
velocity here times omega r
omega r
times r which of course is just omega
omega r squared so once again we do the
same exercise
if our radius goes down what happens to
our angular velocity remember we could
measure this in angles per second or
radians per second well if this go if
this is constant remember we're assuming
that there's no net torque being applied
to the system so we're still in
we're still in this world right over
here if we assume that this thing is
it's changing but the radius were to
change what's going to happen to omega
well omega is going to go
omega is going to go up now likewise if
the radius got longer if the radius got
longer
so the radius got longer what's going to
happen to omega omega is going to go
omega is going to go down so if you
reduce the radius you're going to start
spinning faster if you increase that
radius you're going to start spinning
slower and you have seen this right i
think there's a high likelihood that you
have seen this probably at the olympics
when you have seen figure skaters where
they might start spinning and they have
their arms out so when their arms are
out you could say that their radius is
further out and obviously a figure
skater is a much more complex system
than a than a point mass you can imagine
a figure skater is a bunch of
point masses you could say almost a well
you could just model a figure skaters a
huge number of point masses at different
radii and you would want to sum up their
angular momentum but the the essence of
what happened is happening is is when
her arm is out the the average radius
for when you're calculating
all of the point masses in her arms and
all the rest the average radius is
higher and then when she pulls them in
when she pulls them in that radius goes
down and her
angular velocity goes up and you see
that they start spinning and then
without applying any torque when they
pull their arms in they start spinning
faster and then if they push their arms
out without once again without applying
any torque they start spinning slower